So now it's your turn to run the Hello
World Endpoints application. Go ahead and import the Hello
World Endpoints project into Eclipse. And then you run
your app on localhost. Then try your app in
the web UI. And remember, you get to it
by going to localhost: and then your port number.
Also go ahead and try your app in the
APIs Explorer. And remember, you get to that by going
to localhost:8080 or whatever your port number
is, _ah/api/explorer. We've tested it out on localhost,
then go ahead and run it on appspot. Go to your app on appspot you
go to your-app-id.appspot.com. When you've done all
those things and your app's running on appspot,
go ahead and enter your app ID here so that you can check that it's running.